the richest player in this game just got
banned what is the charge bikers was the
first old school RuneScape player to
ever reach one trillion GP Bank value
and he was recently banned for Real
World Trading essentially trading items
in the game for anything outside of it
no way now at the time of writing old
school RuneScape Bonds were worth
roughly 8.2 million GP and if you buy
the gold legitimately they're worth 8
USD each so if you do the math Biker's
net worth was worth roughly
975,000
[Music]
[Applause]
USD since he didn't keep all of his
money on one account jagex put the
banhammer down on all of them even some
of Biker's friends accounts were banned
for holding his gold and items I just
showed up and I don't now just I don't
even know the guy to be honest with you